it is one of the original American foods
some consider it a delicacy others a
necessity boy stirs have had their ups
and downs over the centuries but this is
a particularly big moment to see what's
happening where this fascinating
industry has been and where it's going
we went directly to the sources off the
coast of Connecticut in the waters of
Long Island Sound the oyster harvest is
underway at Mystic moistures the
operation is still overseen by a
legendary Waterman Jim Marco I've been
at this for 45 years now and I basically
grew up doing this why do you love it so
much
I think it's who we are I didn't pick it
a pic make and that's just the way it is
what is it that people don't understand
about whiskers probably it's one of our
first foods oysters have been consumed
around the world for tens of thousands
of years but they do play an especially
important role in American history for
many Native Americans and settlers from
overseas hoisters were a dietary staple
later they played an even bigger role
especially in the New York City of the
late 1800s hoisters were cheap good and
everywhere
much of lower Manhattan is built on
discarded oyster shells but
overharvesting decimated the business in
the early 1900's it's only in the last
few decades that it really came back
until mid-march what has this been like
for you these last few weeks a lot of
fear and the unknown and the fact that
we had a great business going and in
flash of a second no business is the
switch shut us off Don Marco had to let
most of his workers go he stopped taking
all pay himself now it's all about
holding on and trying to build back up
why voitures don't just feed and employ
people they can be hugely important for
the planet as filter feeders they act as
environmental scrubbers removing
pollutants from the ocean farming them
effectively
makes far more aquatic life possible
you're not fishermen you're you're
farmers we're absolute farmers our farm
is under water it's different than a
normal Dirt Farmer you know you can walk
through your field and see what's going
on ours is on the bottom
when people think American farmers they
a lot of times think middle the country
yeah right yeah now we're farmers you
know I mean the bottom line is we plant
millions and millions of oysters every
year and the volume that we plant way
out strips of volume that we take Markos
right-hand man is Mark Herold between
the coast guard and this your
your life's been on the water absolutely
yep I have a 12 year old son that's a
big part of his life too and we want to
see this keep keep going because it's
what sits in in your blood it's really
there's nowhere else we can go the
oyster business is constantly trying to
invent new ways to produce whether its
twists on classic wild farming or more
complicated hatcheries we saw one of the
latest techniques at norm bloomin Sun
where almost no sales right now means
almost no workers Jimmy bloom runs the
business with his dad this is a nursery
for the seed that comes out of the
hatchery when the seed is sent to us
it's smaller than a grain of sand it's
less than a one millimeter so that seed
could never survive in the wild if we
planted out in the water I'd get swept
away by currents or eaten up by crabs
and fish so what we do here is we nurse
the seed till it's large enough and
robust enough to survive in the wild
the biggest issue today is that 90% of
all Easter's are consumed in restaurants
now none are open except for take out
the the circle is tremendous I mean
we're talking about purveyors farmers
fishermen going from a thousand to zero
in a day you know and prolonging it over
this month two months whatever it is the
impact
everybody's just it's hard Matt's torch
is a chef and restaurant owner in
Connecticut used to serving adventurous
eaters I mean people are are trying to
stuff with me every day and they trust
me I've been in business for 20 years in
Mohawk so you know it's it's like okay
let's go to match and try something new
something we've never had something out
of the box and you know now it's
reversed to give me the most comfortable
thing that reminds me of Mommy cooking
for me at home and that's sort of what
we're we're trying to give you know old
classic recipes like oysters rockefeller
the takeout business is still doing
cooked oysters but really no raw there's
a reason for that people get intimidated
by trying to open an oyster the easiest
with a knife is to find the hinge of the
oyster so you take your your blade you
insert it right into the hinge there and
you just apply a little bit of pressure
just a little bit and you use the knife
I mean it feel good
that's ocean beautiful salty ocean there
you go love it
for those who still crave it straight
from the source they are still making
the trip to Marco's scaled-down
operation we saw somebody pull up here
just as beautiful yes yeah they want to
yeah they want them and the thing that's
nice about it is you know we're here
these oysters that we grow respond in
our hatchery so when you come and get
research from us here they've just been
right here they haven't come from
anywhere else and they haven't seen any
other hands but ours so it's kind of
unique to come up to a farm and actually
buy something like that direct from from
the farmer and I think people are
starting to understand that you know
that control of where your food and
everything comes from I think is a
comforting thing for people also it
absolutely I think is if you don't want
to have roosters just throw in the grill
could not be any easier you did very
well there with the oyster first of all
and it was really eye-opening cuz we've
talked so much about other farmers nice
to hear about these as well although we
wish them better times